These problems are often
called the exploding and
vanishing gradient problems.
And we're going to fix them,
surprisingly in very different ways.
One using a very simple hack, and
the other one with a very elegant but
slightly complicated
change to the model.
The simple hack is called
gradient clipping.
In order to prevent the gradients
from growing inbounded,
you can compute their norm and shrink
their step, when the norm grows too big.
It's hacky, but
it's cheap and effective.
The more difficult thing to
fix is gradient vanishing.
Vanishing gradients make your model
only remember recent events and
forget the more distant past,
which means recurrent neural nets tend
to not work well past a few time steps.